hello my name is kevin halling i'm a
molecular pathologist at the mayo clinic
um i'm going to talk to you today about
the use of rna-seq for detecting
gene fusions and tumors a little
background about myself
i did my pathology residency at the mayo
clinic
from 1991 to 1995
i then started a molecular diagnostics
lab down at indiana university for a few
years
and then i came back to mayo and came
onto staff in 2000
i've been part of the genomics
laboratory ever since
2000 my main interest has been in
developing and and implementing assays
that are used for
to help manage patients with cancer so
that's why i got into this particular
area so today we'll be focusing in on
using rna-seq to detect gene fusions and
tumors
i have no relevant disclosures for this
talk
and the overview of my presentation is
this so we'll start a little bit about
talking about basic cancer concepts
and then we'll talk about the clinical
importance of gene fusion detection
and i'll follow that with a discussion
of the methodology that's used basically
the chemistries that are used
in the bioinformatic analysis and then
i'll finish with
a clinical case that sort of illustrates
how
we clinically interpret gene fusions
that are detected by
rna-seq so i think everybody knows this
but just to remind ourselves cancer is a
genetic disease
and it results from mutations that
in two types of genes oncogenes and
tumor suppressor genes
so as you probably also all know there's
about 20 000 protein encoding genes in
the human genome
but only a small fraction of these about
500 to a thousand have to contribute
the ability to contribute to cancer
formation when mutated
so some genes for instance when they're
mutated such as
hemoglobin collagen albumin and keratin
are unlikely to contribute to tumor
genesis
the mutations in oncogenes like k-ras
and egfr
and tumor suppressor genes like p10 and
p53
do contribute to tumor formation when
they're mutated
again to reiterate there's two types of
genes that uh
cause cancer oncogenes and tumor
suppressor genes and they do this
in sort of opposite fashions so
oncogenes contribute to tumor formation
through activating mutations
in other words mutations that turn
increase the activity of the proteins
that they encode
and tumor suppressor genes contribute to
tumor formation through
inactivating mutations in other words
mutations that turn off the function of
the proteins
that they encode
there's different forms of mutations
some occur at the chromosomal level
and some occur at the molecular genetic
level so examples of chromosome
level mutations include translocations
interstitial deletions conversions and
amplifications
so an example of a chromosomal
alteration is shown off the right that's
the famous philadelphia chromosome
examples of molecular genetic level
mutations and
are point mutations and small insertions
and deletions
so as i said i'm a molecular pathologist
and my job is basically to develop
tests and implement tests that help us
identify these mutations
to help manage the care of patients
so the type of test we use depends on
whether it's a chromosomal level
mutation
or molecular level mutation and some
examples of tests that are used to
detect
chromosomal level mutations include
karyotyping
chromosomal microarray analysis or
assisted site dehybridization
aperionexgen sequencing and
as i will talk about today rna-seq for
gene fusion detection
example molecular level mutation assays
include pcr-based assays
sanger sequencing dna next gen
sequencing
and you can also use rna-seq to pick up
molecular level mutations
but we won't be talking about that today
so this slide just shows examples of
some of the data we get from the
different assays that we use so an
example of microarray analysis shown at
the upper left
of sanger sequencing at the upper right
of next gen sequencing of the lower
right
and fish at the lower left
so why do we care about picking up these
mutations well as i said it can be very
clinically useful it can help establish
a definitive diagnosis for a patient
with cancer it can help determine what
their prognosis is going to be
and it can help guide therapy especially
for targeted therapies
so as i say we'll focus today on the use
of rna-seq for gene fusion detection and
tumors
so let's start with the definition of
what a gene fusion is
a gene fusion is a fusion of two genes
that results from a chromosomal
rearrangement
such as a translocation or an
interstitial deletion or an
inversion or an amplification
and one of the best known examples in
the very first example was
the gene fusion that results from the
philadelphia chromosome that occurs in
patients with chronic myelogenous
leukemia
this was a the very first genetic
alteration that was ever discovered in a
tumor
way back in the 60s by janet rowley
and she found that there's a
translocation in
over 95 percent of cml cases that
joins the long arm of chromosome 22
to the long arm of chromosome 9
and it wasn't known at that time but a
decade or two later they discovered that
what was happening at the molecular
level was a gene fusion
which joined bcr the bcr gene with the
able oncogene
so gene fusions are often a mechanism by
which oncogenes are turned on
or activated and promote tumor genesis
gene fusions are common in tumors
they're com more common in some tumor
types than others
they're quite common in sarcomas maybe
30 to 40 of sarcomas
are found to have a gene fusion a high
proportion of hematologic malignancies
but only about five percent of lung
cancer for instance have a gene fusion
and as i mentioned gene fusions can be
helpful for establishing a diagnosis
guiding
or determining prognosis and guiding
therapy
certain gene fusions are specific to
certain types of sarcomas hematologic
malignancies and salivary gland tumors
and because they're specific they can be
used to help establish a diagnosis
so a good example is a type of sarcoma
known as urine sarcoma frequently has
fusions that involve the ews r1 gene
with other
gene partners so edf r01 phi1
edamp ewsr1 earth
our characteristic of unix sarcoma and
so if a pathologist is wondering
if the tumor he's dealing with is a
ewing sarcoma he may
order an assay that will help identify
these fusions
another good example is at ax3
fkhr fusion that's seen in alveolar
rhabdomyosarcoma
i mentioned the bcr able fusion of
chronic myelogenous leukemia
a couple that are useful for diagnosing
salivary gland tumors are shown at the
bottom there
crtc1 and mammal 2 is seen in
muco-epidermoid carcinoma
and mid nfib is seen in adenoid cystic
carcinoma
now the next slide here shows a not an
uncommon scenario that a pathologist
faces they may be looking down the
microscope and seeing something like you
see off to the right there
which they would describe as a small
round blue cell tumor
the problem i have is that this could be
any one of the number of different types
of tumors
that are listed off to the left
it could be a ewing sarcoma it could be
a peripheral norepidermal tumor it could
be a rhabdomyosarcoma
and the list goes on so they may take
into account
certain the patient's clinical features
for instance the age the gender
where the tumor is located and such
and they may also apply a battery of
immunostains to help make a diagnosis
but sometimes depart despite all that
they're still left with not really
knowing what it is
and they may feel that what would really
help is having an assay
would look for a gene fusion as
characteristic
for a particular type of tumor
how do we traditionally detect gene
fusions well in the past what we've done
is one of two assays either
rtpcr which stands for reverse
transcriptase pcr
shown at the top or fish fluorescence
inside demonization
with rt-pcr what you do basically is you
isolate
rna from the tumor you convert it to
dna through reverse transcription so
that's the rt part
and then you do a pcr reaction with
primers that are designed to pick up the
fusions you're looking for so in this
case what they were looking for was a
jazz f1
cells 12 fusion and so
they did their pcr reaction with these
primers
and they found a fusion which was they
could demonstrate on a
agros shell here and then they sequenced
it at fifth so
this is how it works with rtvcr
the difficulty with rt pcr is you have
to know the two different partners
generally
to make it work fish has the advantage
of not having to know both partners all
you have to know is one partner
and so at the bottom we show basically
what it fish does is it uses a break
apart
fish program strategy where you use
a five prime probe that's colored green
and a three prime probe that's called a
red and if there's a rearrangement such
as occurs with
a fusion these two probes will break
apart
and you'll have ice you'll have separate
red and green probes if there's no
break apart due to a rearrangement
they'll be right on top of each other
and up here is a yellow signal
so fish again has the advantage of
not having to know what the fusion
partner is
so that's both an advantage and a
disadvantage because if you want to know
what the partner is you won't be able to
tell
only our key pcr be able to tell you
that
so this is traditionally how we picked
up g-infusions
uh it's limited to being able to pick up
just
one or two gene fusions at a time
the advantage of of rna-seq is that you
can simultaneously
pick up fusions in the 20 000 genes if
you wanted
any one of 20 000 genes simultaneously
so it's much more powerful
this slide sort of further illustrates
the
um shortcomings of rtbcr for detecting
gene fusions
so we know in ewing sarcoma that the two
most common fusions are ewsr1 fly 1
which accounts for about 85 percent of
tumors and ews r1
and erg which accounts for about 10
percent of tumors
but then there's a variety of other
fusions
that account for just a few percent of
tumors
it's impossible to easily make prime
repairs for all of these so we just
designed
an assay for the top two and
um so you can see that the the problem
here is that
you're going to have a inherent false
negative rate of at least five percent
so we knew with this with our rt pcr
assays there
that there's a potential to miss rare
fusions and rna-seq again doesn't have
that limitation
it could pick up all of these fusions
the other clinical utility of rna
fusion rna-seq for fusion detection
is detecting gene fusions uh
that can help guide targeted therapy
decisions the best example here is for
lung cancer
about five percent of lung
adenocarcinomas have a
fusion involving either the alkanca gene
the vasa gene
or the red oncogene and the value of
picking up these
uh gene fusions is that if for instance
if you had an alk or a ross
uh gene fusion that would predict the
patient would respond to a drug known as
presonative or
or similar drugs if the tumor had a red
gene fusion it would predict that the
patient would respond to
a drug known as bandetnit
but the problems for out for instance
for picking up
fusions and lung cancer same as i sort
of described for
ews r1 fusions and sarcomas
so we know without fusions on lung
cancer that there's a variety of five
prime partners for instance
you can have an eml allow fusion a kif5b
outfusion nbas outfusion so a variety of
five prime partners
um and so again making it difficult to
design
primers for all the different possible
partners in addition the break points
can vary so usually with outlets and
exon 20
but with the five prime partners can be
all over the place
so all of this illustrates the
difficulties of designing rt pcr's
rt pcr assays to pick up all these
different possible fusions and fish
suffers from the
limitation of you would be able to pick
up
most alka rearrangements but it wouldn't
tell you what the partner was
and also that sometimes there's funny
fish bash patterns that result that are
not really
due to fusions
all right so we've been interested in
this since about 2015 we started working
on
rna-seq for gene fusion detection back
then
we decided we wanted to use whole
message rna transcriptome sequencing in
other words
doing rna seq on the entire messenger
rna complement
and but as i said that's about 20 000
genes
we didn't want to look through all that
data we just wanted to look at the genes
we were interested in that was 571 genes
so we get data for 20 20 000 genes but
we bioinformatically mine out
uh just the data for 571 genes of
interest
we went live with this assay into
january 2018.
uh we're currently only offering this
internally to mayo patients because it
uses
snap frozen tumor tissue or tumor
cultures and
logistically it's difficult to send
those in
we hope next year to be able to offer
rnac
on ffbe specimens and
that would allow us to open it up to
outside laboratories in hospitals
as i mentioned we do rna-seq on 20 000
genes
but we only are interested in the
results from 571 genes
and the beginning of that list of 571
genes is
shown here the way we came up with this
571 genes as we went through the
literature to see
what gene fusions have been described in
different tumor types
and then even beyond that what the known
author genes
exist so it's pretty comprehensive
so how do we perform rnac well the first
thing you need to do is obtain a tumor
specimen
you then isolate total rna and
total rna as you remember consists of
ribosomal rna message rna
transfer rna microrna and other types of
rna
but we're just interested for our test
in the message rna
so we have to find a way to specifically
isolate the message rna out from the
total rna
and the way the way we do that is we
take advantage of the fact that
messenger rnas have a poly a tail so we
use oligo
dt beads to isolate the message rna
once we have the message rna we then
convert it to cdna
through reverse transcription and at
that point it basically becomes very
similar to dna and extra sequencing so
we prepare our libraries
we put those libraries on a next-gen
sequencing instrument and we use
illumina instruments
and then we get a lot of data and that
data would be impossible to go through
manually to look for fusions
so we have a bioinformatic pipeline that
crunches that data
and basically sort of spits out the
possible fusions that exist
and then finally we have to go through
that list maybe a small list or a bigger
list
to decide which things are important
that need to be reported
so next-gen sequencing generates tens to
hundreds of millions of reads
and what we do is we align depending on
the type of
what we're trying to accomplish we align
those reads either to the human genome
the transcriptome
or just a specific set of genes
and we have to use customized
bioinformatic pipelines
to determine if there are mutations
present in the reeds
different types of pipelines are
required for different types of
mutations
so typically for dna next-gen sequencing
whether you're looking for a point
mutation or in-dells
you'd use one type of pipeline we use an
entirely different type of pipeline for
gene fusion detection
and another type of pipeline might be
required if you're looking for copy
number operations
this shows an example of dna next gen
sequencing just to illustrate sort of
how next-gen sequencing bioinformatic
analysis works
so as i said you get a lot of reeds and
this is a lung can
a lung cancer sample that was sequenced
from a patient
and the sequencing reads are shown below
these
sort of blue lines each line
represents a single read so there's lots
of reason they keep on going below the
screen
and the reads are aligned to a gene of
interest so in this case i'm interested
in seeing if there's any mutations in
the egfr gene
and if there's uh
no changes shown below there's no
mutation but if there's a change tone
and you can see if you look carefully
you'll see a g in some of these reads
that means there's an alteration so at
this position there's a t
to g change in about 20 percent of the
reads
and that changes an amino acid and egfr
from leucine to arginine
coat on 858 and that's a well-known
mutation that predicts the
response that that patient will respond
to egfr therapies
anti-egfr therapies so that's sort of
how it works for dna nextgen sequencing
the bioinformatic pipeline for rna-seq
is quite different
we're actually looking for weeds that
don't map to the
transcriptome you wouldn't expect in
them after the transcriptome because
they're not
normal they have a fusion of two
different genes
so we take the reads that are initially
thrown out and then look at those to see
if they
there are reason that span two different
genes
and when we see these reeds we call them
supporting leads
they can be take one of several forms
and it's they so they have different
definitions remember this is paired in
the next gen sequencing so we get two
reads for every read
uh we get one in this direction one in
that direction both of them span a
junction
of two genes we call them spanning reads
if they're entirely
contained in the separate genes with all
the split reads
and if one crosses a junction the other
is entirely in the other gene we call
that a hybrid ring
it's not all that important that you
understand the difference between these
but
just realize if we see five or more of
these collectively
uh we can call it the case positive for
a gene fusion
so we call again these are supporting
reads if we see five or more supporting
leads
we consider the case positive for gene
fusion
and this is an example of real life case
so we
where we picked up a novel fusion and a
thyroid cancer it was a fusion between a
gene
known as stxb6 and the oncogene b
raf this fusion had never been described
but other b refugees have been
describing through their
thyroid cancer and down below you can
see these are the individual breeds that
are spanning the junction between the
two genes
we always confirm our fusions with rt
pcr
just to make sure they're real and i'll
tell you that probably over 98 of the
time they confirm
so the assay has very high specificity
not a lot of false positive results
um and this just shows an example of a
fusion we picked up in a liposarcoma
between a gene known as mbm2 and
tmpo and it joined exon 7 of mdm2 to
exon 4 of tmpo
and we confirmed it by agrostellar
electrophoresis
and also sequencing the products
now the bioinformatics is really crucial
to this because
we would not be able to handle all the
data we get without
a bioinformatic pipeline and what our
bioinformatic pipeline does in part is
is to filter out the all the junk
so this is an example of a case that was
was a hematologic term was an acute
myelogenous leukemia
that we picked up a fusion between the
genome and roxa
bronx 1 and ranks 1 t1
but if you look at the bioinformatic
analysis on first pass
it looked like there was a potential for
129 fusions
way more than we can handle interpreting
but if you then ask how many of those
129 fusions overlapped with our 571
genes of interest
it was only 10 genes so we got all the
way
from 129 down to 10.
if we then ask how many of those 10
fusions had five or more supporting
leaves we got it down to five
and we have other things we can
consider for instance is it ever seen in
normal tissues
and is it an exon to exon in frame
fusion
so ultimately we got it all the way down
from 129 possible fusions down to just
two
which is very manageable and actually
the two fusions were
the ranks one rungs one t1 and the
reciprocal translocation
so the bioinformatics is it just works
wonderfully
to get it down to a manageable number
this slide sort of illustrates that so
of 58 tumors that we analyzed
looking for fusions we found in about a
dozen cases no fusion
and about 33 cases we found one fusion
about a dozen cases we found two fusions
and just one case had three fusions
so the point of this slide is just to
show you that
we detected anywhere from zero to three
fusions which is quite manageable in
terms of
interpretation
of course as a clinical laboratory i
have to
we have to make sure that our tests are
accurate and reproducible
so we do what we refer to as
verification which is basically the
established performance characteristics
of the assay
we determine the accuracy of the assay
by
determining the sensitivity and the
specificity
in this case what we did we looked at 41
tumors that we knew had a fusion
based on other reference methods such as
fish or rtpcr
or rna seeking another lab and with our
method we were able to pick up 31 38 of
the 41 fusions for sensitivity for 93
so three false negatives we also looked
at 15 normal tissue specimens and 10
tumor specimens
that we knew should be negative for
fusions and we didn't pick up any
fusions in those samples for a hundred
percent specificity
we also did reproducibility studies both
interaction and true
assay and we found that we had 100
reproducibility
we also did limited detection studies
where we made dilutions of tumor to see
how low we could go
and we generally found we could go down
to at least 12.5 percent tumor
and sometimes as little as 3 tumor
depending on how heavily the
fusion was expressed
okay so i mentioned that we had three
cases uh three false negative cases up
here
uh with our sensitivity but it's
important to realize that we also picked
up 22 fusions
in 17 tumor specimens that had not been
detected by other methods
so there was a big net gain and total
number of fusions detected
and 18 of those 22 fusions were novel
fusions that had not been previously
observed or described in the literature
and we confirmed all of them by rtbcr
now not all of those um fusions
22 are are necessarily clinically
significant and i'll talk a little bit
about that in a second
they're real biologically real but
whether they're clinically significant
is a different question
so we described our verification studies
in a paper and journal molecular
diagnostics in 2018 if you're interested
in reading more
okay the final thing i want to touch on
is how do we interpret gene fusion that
are detected by rna-seq in other words
how do we know that they're
clinically important as i said not all
gene fusions are affected by rna-seq are
clinically significant
occasionally some of them may represent
technical artifacts
and we hope that the bioinformatics
leaves out most of those
and some may be real fusions but
clinically insignificant what we refer
to as
passenger mutations that result from
genomic instability in cancers
and so the next few slides will use a
case study to illustrate how we
determine if a fusion is clinically
significant using a combination of
bioinformatics
and clinical interpretation that's based
on
databases and literature so this is a
very interesting case this was actually
the first
case we ran through the clinical assay
it was a 72 year old man who had a
destructive 4 centimeter tumor of the
mandible
the pathologist diagnosed it as the
spindle cell
sclerosing rhabdomyosarcoma
and this was the fusion filtering
process for that particular case
of the potential for 194 fusions but
whittled all the way down to one real
fusion
and i'm just showing you that so 109 94
possible fusions only eight of them
overlapped with
the 571 genes of interest
only one had five or more supporting
reads
there were none of them that were that
one didn't have a was not a read-through
of that which means
occasionally you see transcription
reading uh
through genes goes from one gene to the
next and those can appear as artifacts
so
that wasn't like that for this case uh
we didn't observe this particular fusion
in any normal specimens
so it's not a benign thing and finally
it was in frame so bottom line is 194
fusions whittled down to one real fusion
and this is what it looked like so it
was a fusion between an oncogene known
as
phos and a transcription factor known as
tfcp2
it joined exon one through six of phos
two exons two through 15 of
of tfc p2 this fusion had never been
described before fast fusions have been
described but never with this gene
we confirmed the fusion by rtbcr shown
off to the left as a band on the august
gel
and so the next thing i did was i went
to the databases to see if this fusion
had ever been described before
and while phose fusions have been
described they've this particular
prosthesis has never been described
so you can see some of the few
fustfusions that have been described
such as phosphate 301 and 2 fuss ddit3
flusser and this is just shown these
columns are showing you how common they
are so the most common
fusions are plus ddit3 and kryp3o182
these fast fusions are observed in
different types of tumors for instance
fuss
ddit3 is observed in myxoloid
liposarcoma and actually finding this
fusion is very helpful for establishing
that diagnosis
but as i said the fusion we saw was
never described before the literature
until
ironically just a few days later when we
saw a paper coming
into the literature out of europe um
that described a completely novel group
of
epithelial spindles around the
myosarcomas that were characterized by
fossenty of cp2 fusions so
brand new so this is uh when you see
sarcomas with this particular type of
fusion it's a particular type of
rhabdomyosarcoma
and we described our experience in a
paper a few
few months later
that's the all of my size so just to
summarize
the rna-seq is a powerful tool for
detecting gene fusions and tumors
and clinically it can be used to help
establish a diagnosis
especially for sarcomas and hematologic
tumors
and it can help guide therapy derma
basically can help determine if patients
are candidates for targeted therapy
best example being alkah and lung cancer
but there's other many other examples
and then finally
i hope i show you showed you the process
that we use to determine if
gene fusions are clinically significant
because some can represent technical
artifacts
that we try to weed out with
bioinformatics
and others while they may be real
biologically real may not be clinically
significant because they may represent
passenger alterations
that result from genomic instability
the distinguishing of clinically
significant from insignificant
is highly dependent on our
bioinformatics and
our post-analytical clinical
interpretation
so i hope i've shown you that rna-seq is
is is a very powerful tool and i think
that it's going to be used
quite commonly for patients with
advanced
cancers in the coming decade thank you
very much